hey everyone thank you for coming out my
name is Deeksha hanim I'm a data
scientist at Walmart technology downtown
today I'm going to talk about
multilingual embeddings and how you can
use them to scale your NLP models to
work with different languages other than
just English Before we jump into
multilingual embeddings I want to give a
very quick introduction about word
embeddings
how many of you are familiar with word
embeddings or used word embeddings in
your work good
so world and buildings as you may be
aware are vector representations of
words so basically converting words into
numbers so that you can use your regular
traditional data science models on
natural language so basically vector
representations are such that you're
semantically similar words or similar
meaning words or words are appeared in
similar contexts and documents have
similar vectors and they appear together
in the vector space so this can be
useful in like document classification
semantic search and many other NLP
applications the most common example
that we see is this example right here
about man women king and queen so it's
basically showing you that the vector
difference between man and women is the
same as the vector difference between
king and queen so man is to women as
king is to queen so you can draw these
types of analogies from vector
representations in the way we generally
use word embeddings in practice is
mostly through pre-trained word
embeddings such as you have word to make
fast text or glove glove to make sort of
models you have pre-trained word
embeddings that are basically a million
or
more words and their vector
representations that have been trained
on large corpora like Wikipedia or news
datasets and things like that the way we
generally use say for a document
classification task is you have you
start by collecting labelled documents
so for example if you want to say build
a classification model to categorize
different news articles into different
categories that they fall into like you
know sports or politics and things like
that so you start by collecting label
documents so each document you have a
label of what it belongs to for your
training data set and then a typical
pipeline would look like for say if
you're using pre trained water back
embeddings for each word in each of your
documents you would look up the pre
trained what what imbedding and then for
each document now that you have this
collection of word embeddings you want
to represent your document as as a
collection of numerical features right
so now you have these word embeddings
that are like building blocks and then
you take those and convert them or
combine all of them for each document
into a single document vector
representation you can do that in
multiple ways one of the common ways is
to do element wise mean of all the words
in your document and you get a document
vector representation you can avoid this
if you're using like you know document
vector representation of models as well
like dr. Beck which directly gives you
an embedding for your document instead
of starting with like word vectors and
then once you are at a document vector
representation you can use basically
you're now representing your documents
as numbers so you can use these vectors
as features for a classification model
such as logistic regression or SVM and
so on so once you have the trained model
now you have a new collection of
documents which you don't know which
categories they belong to you use this
classification model
and you get your document document
vector representations and use those
along with your trained model to predict
the categories that they fall into now
the question here is what if my data is
in multiple languages this is especially
common with MNCs where you have
operations in different countries so
your data need not necessarily be in
English it may be in Spanish or Chinese
and so on so imagine you have this
document classification task and you
have started with English you deployed a
model and then you have another business
unit in Mexico or something and they
have data in Spanish that they also want
to utilize this model for one thing you
could do is start the whole process all
over again start collecting label
documents in Spanish and train another
model and do the same process basically
solve the problem from scratch for a
different business unit or you could use
a translation service like you know you
have all these documents that you will
translate into English and then use your
original English classifier but all of
these solutions are very time-consuming
they will introduce a lot of noise into
your model especially with the
translation service you are essentially
adding another machine learning model
before your original machine learning
model so now the errors are going to get
multiplied right so and also it's going
to add a lot of cost to your project
so there are pre-trained word embeddings
in different languages as well so you
get just as you get pre trained word
embeddings for english you also have
four I think at least 30 other languages
you have pre trained word word inverter
back models but the thing is all of them
are in different vector spaces so the
word that means football in English and
the word that means football in Spanish
may not have similar vectors so you
cannot use one single model to train
both English and
Spanish the answer to that is
multilingual embeddings which basically
solves this question of you know when I
have multiple languages do those vectors
align in the same space or not for
example here I have taken the example of
English and Spanish so this is using the
multilingual universal sentence encoded
by Google I just created a simple plot
of you know I got the vectors for man
King woman and queen and also the same
vectors for the corresponding words in
Spanish you can see that the
corresponding words are in similar
vector spaces on the plot so this means
that you know for example if I have a
document where people are conversing
with each other and they may be
switching between English and Spanish
for example they may be talking about
something and they said man in something
and then the words for king and queen
were maybe in Spanish in the same
document because the vectors are aligned
properly you can now even if you train
one single model you will be able to
capture both English and Spanish words
without having to do multiple models so
there are a couple of pre train
multilingual embeddings available one of
the first ones that I used was by
Facebook it's called Muse a multilingual
unsupervised and supervised embeddings
the way they did it is they took
separate embeddings for 30 different
languages and they used bilingual
dictionaries to basically map vectors
from one language in another language
onto the same vector space such that
similar words in both languages have
similar vectors and that's that's the
way they trained it so now you have all
these vectors for 30 different languages
that are aligned
one single vector space so and it's very
easy to use if you're already using say
if you have a jensen model of what to
attend same model that you're using you
can just replace the warwick embeddings
file that comes for english with the
multilingual one and now all of a sudden
you can use your same model for
different languages but the other
interesting one that I have been using
most is called the multilingual
universal sentence encoder by Google
this is an open source model that was
released I think around July of this
year it is a part of the broader
universal sentence encoder family of
models that's also open sourced by
Google it is available as pre-trained
modules on tensorflow hub so these dog
these models they take a sentence or
document as an input and return a
document embedding the way they train
these is for each document they average
the word vectors and then put the
resulting sentence and code encode into
a deep averaging neural network and then
the they train the encoder such that it
performs well on different NLP tasks
like you know sentiment classification
or semantic retrieval or translation in
case of multilingual and universal
sentence encoder they used a bunch of
different data sets of basically pairs
of sentences
translated by humans or sometimes by
even I think Google Translate and and
then use that as a training data to
train this sentence and corridor model
it is available as a pre trained model
so it's you can literally use this as a
black box of for example the code I have
right here is you have to you have to
use tensorflow and it's a module on
tensorflow hub so you just load the
model and then this is a tensorflow 2.0
example so you just define a function
called embed
say I want to for any list of documents
that I give I want to get a document
embedding for each of those documents so
you just say model input and then
whatever documents list you have you
pass that as a parameter to your embed
function so it's as simple as that you
don't have to figure out how to train
your model or even get like you know a
lot of training data so it's very useful
but I will also say this is a little
computationally expensive model so if
you're running on multiple like millions
of documents say you would probably need
to use a GPU and set up some more
advanced pipelines to make sure you know
it's it's optimal and you're not wasting
from pure time too much this is a
language agnostic model it supports 16
different languages the ones that I have
used just English and Spanish but it
also supports Chinese Italian Arabic too
I think two different types of Chinese
Japanese Korean and a lot of different
languages just as an example for the
semantic similarity this is just one
single sentence it's welcome to simple
yet surprisingly powerful multilingual
natural language understanding models
what people mean matters more than the
language they speak right so in we have
divided these this big sentence into
multiple like smaller phrases and for
each of those phrases and I'm also I
also have the the language translation
in two different languages so this is in
German and this corresponds to welcome
to simple yet surprisingly powerful I
think this is I'm not sure which
language this is but anyway you get the
gist so the embeddings that come out of
the multilingual sentence encoder or
normalized so if you want to get some
semantic similarity you can just do a
dot product of the vectors that you have
and that gives you a cosine similarity
score if you're familiar with cosine
similarity that you do in
text analytics in general it's basically
just like taking two vectors and seeing
what is the cosine angle between them
and using that as a measure for how
similar your documents are when you do
that this is the heat plot that you get
so you can see that the diagonal is the
extreme red which means that the vectors
for this sentence and this sentence are
extremely similar and and also you can
see for example natural language
understanding and the language they
speak both of them have the word
language in them so you might expect
that you know natural language
understanding will have some similarity
to the vector for language they speak in
Arabic so it is like it's not completely
correlating but also you have likes some
slight orange here so that that's just
an example of how well the semantic
similarity works with universal sentence
encoder now in my application I have had
documents where people are talking in
multiple languages and just switching
over so like they start in English but
in between they have like some Spanish
paragraph or something and then they
have something in English again so when
I put this when I put all my documents
through the universal sentence encoder
and got the document embedding sort of
them and then use that as input to my
document classification task it worked
really well for me so I thought it may
be useful Google does provide a lot of
resources on TF hub to be able to look
at you know they have a lot of models on
let me show you so DF hub dot dev is
where they publish all these modules and
if you just click on all models they
have about I think hundred models over a
hundred models and you can filter by
problem domains so if you're looking for
embedding related models
you can just click on that and and then
you'll see a lot of these different
models the one I have used is universal
sentence encoder multilingual but they
also have a question answer specific pre
trained model as well which is this and
then there are a bunch of other models
with examples and collab notebooks
I just want to take you through this
collab notebook for universal sentence
encoder and this is the example that I
was showing you earlier where you are
just passing in sentences like this so
welcome to simple yet is and then the
German equivalent of that and then so on
and then you can just very clearly see
the similarity between these sentences
is extremely high when they correlate
and very low when they don't correlate
there's also an example of creating a
multilingual semantic similarity search
engine within this collab notebook I
would highly encourage you to take a
look into it this is basically they
download data from a new source yes so
this is new sentences in multiple
languages from news commentary corpus so
now we are downloading data for I think
Arabic Chinese English Russian Spanish
and what you do is run all these
sentences through the through the
encoder and get the get vectors for each
of these sentences using its it's just
this code and then after that you build
an index of the semantic vector so now
you have all these vectors for different
sentences you a building a very simple
index to find given any vector an
approximate nearest neighbor for that
vector so the implication would be that
you know say your suppose searching for
the stock market fell four points and if
it's only in English
if you're only searching for English
it's returning sentences like this
historically the stock market has
performed well and things like that so
basically a semantic similarity search
but now say because you're using this
multilingual model you're only using one
model and you have multiple languages
within your data set and you'll see that
it works well even for different
languages so now I'm searching for some
stock market fell four points but in my
data set I have like I think I had
Chinese Russian Spanish and things like
that so it's returning sentences that
are similar to the stock market fell
four points from multiple languages you
can use this in say in your own work if
you have multiple data in multiple
languages and you want to do a semantic
similarity search this is exactly how it
would work you wouldn't have to do
multiple models or anything like that
and here I'm trying like my own like
other queries I tried for rising real
estate prices and I have no idea what
these mean I'm not conversant in any of
these languages but I searched for this
say on google translate and it I like
for the top sentences like Chinese
Russian everything corresponds directly
to real estate so that's how it has been
useful for me I have used mostly for
document classification but you could
also use it for different other multiple
NLP tasks that's all I had actually and
thank you so much personally it has been
a huge difference because earlier we'd
have to build models for each individual
business domain separately now we have
been able to end especially because this
is a sentence encoder I don't even have
to like get word embeddings and then do
was separate like a whole pipeline to
get a sentence embedding
out of the word embeddings and things
like that so and and also I think maybe
because this has been trained
specifically for performance on NLP
tasks it works really well for document
classification and I'm able to use
multiple languages like I said and even
if your document has multiple languages
in within your document it still works
well
yeah I prefer the Google one I also use
the Facebook's muse it's called
multilingual unsupervised and supervisor
meetings it's easy to replace
Jensen model that you may already be
using but it's not as effective as the
Google one
I have not yet I'm not yet but yeah I
think this is something that I would
want to explore further
yeah I've used the pre-trained model to
build my own like document
classification model but we have not
tried to like tweak the free train model
or anything does that answer your
question
no I have not tried to build my own
model because especially for us the
concern is that we don't have as much
labeled training data in general to
train such our deep learning model so we
prefer using a free trained model that
that's already been trained on a large
corpus know so it was until recently I
think the Google TF hub module did not
allow you to fine-tune it it was a
complete black box but I think recently
with the tensorflow 2.0 version they
also introduced a capability to let you
find T on the model if you want to but I
haven't looked into it
[Applause]